Now that we have what equation, we need to set up another one. The other
equation needs to involve interest. I know if I add the interest from one
account and the interest from the other account, I'll get my total interest of
$787.50. But I need to find the interest first. To find the interest, we take
the rate and multiply it by the amount of money. For example, one of their rates
is 7 point 5 percent. And, the amount of money that I invested at 7 point 5
percent was, well, x. I don't know it. Remember, our equation should involve two
variables, x and y. So, we need to make sure that it appears in the terms. We
convert the percentage rate, 7 point 5 percent, to a decimal, and multiply it by
x. So, this is the first term. So what are the other terms in the equation. What
should go here in the second interest. What should go here in the total
interest. You can write the terms in these boxes.